London police have launched a huge
manhunt after an improvised explosive
device caused a fire on a subway train
packed with commuters this morning now
sources tell CBS News a bomb detonator
went off but did not trigger the main
explosive at least 22 people were hurt
witnesses say it was chaos
as I approached the station ever almost
like piling out like people weren't even
running they were falling over each
other well a big band in my left hand
side so I turned my head and I saw the
big fire fireballs first responders
evacuated the Train at Parsons Green
station in southwest London if this is
confirmed as a terror attack it would be
the fifth major attack of the year in
Britain Charlie d'Agata is at the scene
of the fire the area is now blocked off
for the investigation Charlie good
morning
good morning to you are learning more
about the device left behind on that
subway train now turns out to have had a
timer and screws the type of thing used
as shrapnel in similar devices as this
pictures posted on social media appear
to show that the device on fire a bucket
inside a freezer bag with wires sticking
out of it now sources tell CBS News that
that bucket contained powerful
explosives found in recent terrorist
attacks London Ambulance say a number of
people have been hospitalized from the
initial blast from from burns or
injuries sustained in the Stampede the
panic to try to escape that pack train
none of the injuries is said to be
life-threatening
now there's now as you mentioned a
manhunt underway for the person
responsible for leaving that device
behind you can hear these helicopters
overhead no arrests have been made
Jeff Charlie d'Agata in London Charlie
thank you